people have a right to think he actually
committed suicide people have a right to
think that he was murdered but the
evidence points towards murder
we know that all the default protections
were turned off that people heard
screaming and yelling
and shouting breathe breathe epstein and
then he told friends they're trying to
kill me over the telephone
they're trying to kill me you got to get
me out of here i'm not going to commit
suicide i didn't try to commit suicide
it's like a
string on a sweater you pull that string
out on that sweater
and the whole thing can unravel
you rightfully explain that most people
get recruited by evil because it's a hot
secretary and that's actually how most
satanists
recruit people and that's how it begins
but the way it's been described to me
is it circles of corruption they have
all the information they know where the
bodies are buried
they had underground dungeons
underground passages
are you saying you think that epstein
would have been involved with like
actual human sacrifices at satanic
rituals
absolutely